The nucleoside Innovation for which the
Nobel Prize here was
given was the conversion of the uracil
that is the natural nucleotide in mRNA
to something called pseudo urine now
pseudo iDine is something that is
chemically sufficiently similar that it
fits in an mRNA chain the same way that
a UR wood and it allows the translation
by the
ribosome to occur but what it does is it
interrupts the body's natural tendency
to break down the mrnas so imagine that
your body produces a lot of mrnas that
produce proteins but those mrnas are
constantly being taken apart and so the
way the body regulates whether or not
you're producing proteins or not is
whether it introduces new mrnas the old
ones having been broken down so by
introducing so I the the weird caveat
here is that pseudo urine is actually
something that nature does occasionally
introduce into mrnas but it does it very
sparsely that is to say if nature
decides that a particular MRNA would be
better off in a more stable form it may
introduce a pseudo iDine but it doesn't
do it across every uracil in the message
so what these folks have done is they
have introduced a whole slew of
pseudouridines
making the MRNA transcript extremely
durable just question uh you said a
whole slew so um not all the G okay
that's what I thought now there's also a
question about um manufacturing and
technique and how effective the
intention is all it's not you know a
whole slew sounds like there a lot more
than one but um but the if if it's osil
is replaced with pseudo iDine that's a
different kind of situation right now um
a couple of uh inter ing points one
Let's uh give them the benefit of the
doubt and by them I do not only mean uh
these now Nobel laurates but um those
involved in the program to produce these
vaccines who did not initially know
whether or not they would be successful
at producing enough protein to induce an
immune
response they might have thought well
one of the challenges is that the MRNA
is going to be rapidly broken down and
that that may mean that even though we
have introduced something that might
technically be able to produce an immune
response it won't be around long enough
to succeed at it so they may have turned
up the dial on stabilizing the MRNA
thinking that that was necessary to get
any effect at
all that said what they did was
absolutely Reckless especially in an
environment in which the testing was
extremely
truncated
so
they've they've stabilized the mrnas to
a degree that they cannot say in advance
they've done it in a way that is most
unnatural and now they've been given a
prize
for um that stabilization which the Noel
Committee in awarding the prize says was
essential to producing a viable vaccine
now that's not true and I would ask
people to go look at Chris martinson's
analysis of this but Chris Martinson
points out that there are versions of
the vaccine even mRNA based versions of
the vaccine that were not pseudo urine
stabilized and were initially tested and
did produce an anti a detectable
antibody response which means that the
choice to do this was not inherently
necessary it's possible that a version
of the vaccines which had not been
pseudo urine stabilized might have
worked but we never got a chance to find
out all
right so with that as background I now
want to look at these two pieces of
video the first one from the Nobel
committee itself which held a miniature
press conference and the first thing
you're going to hear is a Chinese
journalist in English asking a question
about the long-term safety of these
vaccines and then you will hear uh the
answer as delivered by by the committee
go ahead and show
that uh hello this is Ty media from
China and with the mRNA we don't know
the long-term effect yet so do you have
any concern over
that uh Rickard would you like to
respond to that
question yes um of course you know MRA
vaccines have only been given for a
certain amount of time which begs your
question having said that of course the
MRNA vaccine that is given is very
transient and the fact that 13 billion
people have gotten the virus vaccine
virus and uh I mean that and the amount
of side effects noted today is extremely
limited so uh I don't think it's a it's
a major
concern anyone else want to add to that
or that's fine I guess I think
that's Well it can't be integrated into
the nucleus into the DNA and that's you
know a safety precaution the adverse EV
effects that's been noted is mostly a
mild my carditis or par
myocarditis mainly affecting young
males but that normally resolves without
any long-term
effect okay
now I find this piece of video shocking
because it no nobody who is familiar
with the
actual vaccine technology and the
evidence that has emerged could possibly
deliver this answer in good faith this
answer is too far from reality to be
believed and yet these people appear
Earnest in delivering it they do not
appear to be knowingly lying and yet
they essentially have to be now notice
that the first thing that the person
identified as Rickard says is that we
don't have to worry about the long-term
Hazard of the MRNA vaccines
because their presence is
transient now notice this exact
committee has just given the most
coveted scientific prize there is for
specifically the innovation of making
the MRNA less transient precisely they
have given it for this thing and yet he
says transient as if he is not just
calling into question the wisdom of this
committee that has awarded uh a prize
for making it less transient now how not
transient is it let's talk about
specifically the mrnas the answer is we
don't know how not transient it is what
we do know is that it has been found two
months after inoculation it's not that
it stopped being findable after two
months we stopped looking after two
months we know that it persists for 2
months and then how long after that we
cannot say that is anything but
transient it is um pratal does not begin
to describe the way this mRNA behaves in
fact when I spoke to Robert Malone about
it I used the analogy that this was like
like a fiberglass log in a zoo exhibit
right it looks like a log but it's not
being broken down by termites and fungi
because it's made of fiberglass this is
a permanent feature of the environment
but it's it's even it's it's even worse
even right um as as you all know which
is that it's not it's not just a static
permanent feature of uh you know we
don't know permanent but it's not just a
static very longlived feature of your
body now it is a factory uh it it it has
the instructions to make the in this
case the spike protein um and so
presumably we'll continue to do so so
long as it exists um so it's not just uh
floating about um ready to be uh
disassembled by your immune system as uh
the effects the the product of a normal
vaccine of a traditional vaccine would
be um it is a factory for the production
of the the antigen that you are trying
to get immune response for against um
that is itself been stabilized so that
it can attain a less transient State yep
okay uh Rickard also says that the side
effects to date are
limited um what actually the side
effects the severe ones are off the
charts in every place that we have
monitored now the only place that you
can claim that that's not true are
places where we haven't looked but in
the VS System the yellow card system the
military system we see an off the charts
adverse event signal what's more when
this has been looked at carefully in a
scientifically rigorous way we have seen
evidence of an off- thee chart signal
even in the clinical trial data so
there's a paper which uh we will um link
to the description of this video um
first first office author is uh Joe
freman Peter Doshi is the last author
that looked at the clinical trials and
found something like a one in
800 incidents of a severe adverse
effect so that is not a minor level and
what's
more that measurement 1 in 800 severe
adverse reactions in the clinical trials
is the tip of the iceberg inherently
because it was measured over such a
short period of time that is to say
anything that happened months down the
road from vaccination was not captured
in that in fact fizer's data only goes
one month so in one month they saw a 1
in 800 level of severe Adverse Events
that's not rare and we are not talking
about Minor Adverse Events
either um and then the next gentleman
says that mostly what we see is
myocarditis he is for some reason he
says well but that's mostly uh in young
males I don't know why anybody is
supposed to be comforted by that um but
he says mostly myocarditis mostly in uh
young males and mostly it
resolves without any long-term effect
which is nonsense myocarditis is an
inherently serious condition we see a
very powerful signal that looks strongly
associated with vaccinations uh with
these
vaccinations uh of uh all cause
mortality that does not begin with the
onset of coid but does begin with the
onset of the vaccination campaign so
there's every reason to think that this
isn't true that it's not limited um to
myocarditis and that the rate is very
high and serious and some of these
things are uh life shortening in fact um
one of the things I wanted to talk about
a little bit later but we I think we can
go there now um is is this published in
nature uh this last week coid vaccines
linked to unexpected vaginal bleeding a
large cohort study measured how
frequently women women reported bleeding
after receiving Co 19 Jabs and uh I was
going to bring this up on the last show
because this is relevant to um to the
lambasting of Naomi Wolf by the
mainstream media including by Naomi
kleene and her new book doubleganger um
because wolf was one of the people who
was saying this over and over and over
again and got you know roundly mocked
and demonetized and deplatformed in all
of these things um for for saying this
and now that it's in nature we're
allowed to talk talk about it but there
are um we are being assured nevertheless
uh that they are safe and effective and
um the link in the peace in nature as to
their safety and
Effectiveness uh is
to uh this article which you can now
show Zach um from February
2021 their evidence in a in an article
published now from a cohort study now
demonstrating that actually the people
like Naomi wolf who were yelling from
the rooftops about um menstrual effects
in women who were getting these shots uh
our Assurance is that these are safe and
effective goes back to February 2021 Co
vaccines and safety what the research
says Co vaccines and safety what the
research says as the vaccines are rolled
out researchers learning about the
extent and nature of side effects uh
they assure us um that it's it's
basically fine again this is proof now
that these vaccines are safe and
effective from February 2021 but even so
they acknowledge um that there are side
effects I got the vaccine six hours
later I had chills and high fever muscle
aches I went to bed for 24 hours um
these uh yeah so you had you thing to
say here yeah I was going to say that
this you know in the
um the the large quiver of tricks that
Pharma plays this idea of looking way
back into the early days in order to
figure out whether something is safe and
effective is uh clearly used again and
again and it's used in fact in the
trials themselves so one of the things
that happens is in these trials there is
an ethical requirement that if a drug is
so good it is it is demonstrated to be
so good in the process of the clinical
trial that it would be unethical not to
give it to everybody then you un L the
trial effectively ending it making it
impossible to find long-term effects so
T Pharma Targets this and in fact if you
couple this with what we've covered here
before the Norman Fenton and Martin uh
mcneel um uh piece the so-called Cheap
Trick where they create the impression
of efficacy by using a cut off date of
two weeks and they classify everybody
who gets um sick in those two weeks as
unvaccinated at thereby generating an I
think it was 83 plus% impression of
efficacy just simply through um shifting
categories having nothing to do with the
effect of the drug in question so fent
and Mel just to remind everyone are
uncovering the statistical trick uh by
which anything could be demonstrated
could be demonstrated in quotes uh to be
effective simply by categorizing things
in the way uh that these results have
been categorized y um I am experiencing
a bit of Terror it's McNeil not Neil did
I did I mess it up have I added a
syllable to his name in any way in any
case let's maybe you could figure that
out um but let's continue what we've
yeah go ahead yeah so
um in the middle of talking about um the
the awarding of the Nobel and Physiology
and Medicine uh to the two people who
have invented I I think rather than
discovered in this case um and of course
the award could be given for either
invention or Discovery um but the
invention of a way to make less
transient and more stable uh the MRNA
that is used in the MRNA platform um
that is being given in these so-called
vaccines um we are talking about we are
you know seeing the committee saying oh
the effects um any side effects are
going to be transient because the
vaccines themselves are transient when
in fact the award has been given
precisely um for the for for the trick
for the for the scientific trick the
impressive um if not necessarily um safe
scientific trick of making um of
replacing urell with pseudo Idan and
thus making the entire object uh more
likely to stick around in the body um we
see new evidence of uh of even nature
saying ah there's workout now that says
yeah all those women who were saying
they were experiencing uh weird
menstrual effects we're actually right
but nothing to see here folks there
still safe and effective here check out
this thing that we wrote back in
February 2021 and just one more Link in
that chain before we go back to um uh
the Nobel story as long as we're digging
deep in the nature archives which we
didn't want to do it was nature that is
citing their own archives pretty deep
from two and a half years ago as
evidence that these vaccines are safe
and effective they have in that same
safe and effective article from February
221 a related article
called um how Co unlocked the power of
RNA and this is from January 2021 so we
are going way back in time right this is
remember the the first people were
getting their vaccinations and this was
mostly uh medical providers in Janu in
December 2020 so in January 2021 there
are not that many people who have and at
that point many people are clamoring for
these things that people are trying to
get vaccinated but they're just it's the
roll out is is careful uh I mean it's
fast but um what we are told is there's
not enough right and this of course
increases demand uh because people want
something that's insured Supply um but
in the middle of that we have how Co
unlocked the power of RNA published in
nature January 2021 let me just read a
couple of sections from this from this
article five years and one Global
pandemic later RNA vaccines are proving
their worth last month two RNA vaccine
candidates one from us pharmaceutical
Giant fiser and bio entech in Main's
Germany and another from Mna in
Cambridge Massachusetts one emergency
approval from regular leaders in several
countries to fight Co 19 remember when
that was new right so go down in this
article a little bit more side effects
can be troubling the RNA technology has
proved itself but it's not done yet says
Philip dormitzer head of viral vaccines
research at fiser and a former colleague
of Gils at novares and now that we've
seen it work for Co 19 it's tempting to
want to do more and I think I have one
more little section stability and safety
despite its many potential advantages
today's RNA vaccine technology leaves
room for improvement this technology is
still super early says Robin shatak an
immunologist in Imperial College London
and we're going to see multiple
generations and iterations over the
coming years I
suspect and then we have um three
examples of um the problems the
potential problems with this uh vaccine
again um first there's the issue of Cold
Storage there's another challenge so far
RNA vaccines tested for human use
against disease Co 19 or otherwise have
generally required a double dose to
effective and judging by poor compliance
with other multi-dose vaccines many
people who get the first shot probably
won't get the second well that didn't
turn out to be the case by and large
although some people stopped at one new
Delivery Systems could fix that at vs
Technologies in Cambridge Massachusetts
for example research have developed a
wearable skin patch started with tiny
silk tip dissolvable micro needles that
slowly trickle vaccine into the body W
and finally administering the vaccine in
drips instead of all at once could help
to solve a third drawback side effects
severe reactions although transient do
seem to be more common with Co 19 shots
than with other immunizations more than
80% of people who received the Mna
vaccine and clinical trials had some
type of systemic reaction to the shot
with bouts of fatigue muscle pain and
other issues that often proved briefly
debilitating I share that to remind us
and to alert those who weren't aware
that back in January of 2021 even nature
was pointing out that one of the
problems with these plat with this
platform that the entire world is being
encouraged nay in some cases mandated to
get was severe side effects side effects
so much more widespread and also severe
in individuals than other vaccines had
that it was worth mentioning as a
possible reason that maybe this wasn't
such a good idea after all well but
they're allowed to say stuff like that
we are Heretics if we say things like
that right so you know you have to check
your privilege and by doing that that
means you got to check which privileges
you are allowed based on your position
in the universe right all right so I
wanted to cover one more thing from that
video before we move on to the next one
okay um he makes the claim the second
speaker makes the claim that the MRNA is
not integrated into the nuclear DNA and
therefore that is another reason um to
uh imagine that long-term effects are
not a problem now this may technically
be right but it ought to be no comfort
based on what we Now understand and mind
you this is a modern video so he has
every reason to understand everything
that you and I understand whether or not
the message in the MRNA Finds Its way
into the nucleus and is ever integrated
into the nuclear Genome of your
cells something else does appear to be
making its way into the nucleus from
these vaccines and this is a mind
blowing story which we have yet to cover
in detail but this is largely the work
of Kevin mckernin and an anonymous
account JY leaks um on Twitter and I
would say um it is clear that mckernan
has Unearthed a tremendous amount of DNA
contamination in the vials this is work
done where somebody one of the people
who was involved in the vaccination
campaign saved every vial and that left
a residual that could be tested for its
content so this is a fairly large sample
of vials and what what mckernan
Unearthed was a huge amount of DNA
contamination what the hell is DNA doing
in there at all and the story behind
this is mindblowing and it will have a a
resonance to something that uh you were
talking about a couple weeks
ago the explanation for this DNA is that
there were
apparently two mechanisms for generating
the contents the active contents of
these vaccines the MRNA
transcripts the first one one was used
for the clinical trials it was not
sufficiently productive to be able to
scale it up to vaccinate billions of
people so a second mechanism for
generating these transcripts was um uh
utilized that involved uh
plasmids in bacteria so in other words
they involved DNA in the production of
these mRNA transcripts and they did not
purify the stuff out the stuff is there
in huge huge quantities what did they do
they broke it up they used restriction
enzymes to break up these DNA fragments
so what you effectively have is a chaos
of different length pieces of DNA that
do appear to be integrating into the
nuclear genome now
this is a disaster because there's all
sorts of stuff in there like um a great
set of evolutionary opportunities for
that DNA potentially it's at the very
least um like broadcasting a powerful
mutagenic signal arbitrarily into the
tissues of the body and I would point
out why that phrasing mut broadcasting a
mutagenic s uh signal into the tissues
of the body let's imagine that the
chopping up of this DNA effectively
produces a random distribution of
lengths or you know a bell curve you're
going to have some intermediate and then
you know some very long fragments some
very short fragments okay but some
chaotic assortment and then those things
are going to integrate based on
idiosyncrasies of the nuclear genome
what has an affinity for a particular
piece that causes that piece to stick
there and then insert
itself now the problem here is that you
are introducing stuff stuff that is not
um biologically inert inherently some of
these fragments are going to be so short
that they can't really encode anything
important the most they can do is
disrupt something important which can be
catastrophic but some other things like
uh there's a um Simeon virus 40 promoter
that McCaron has found uh that could
actually take stuff that's supposed to
be inactive in the genome and turn it on
now the question is what might this for
example have to do this whole story is
so crazy the turbo cancers remember
turbo cancers how people were reporting
oh my God you're seeing people who've
been in remission for a long period of
time who suddenly have rapid growth of
their their their tumor or people who
were free from tumors who suddenly are
diagnosed with them this is a pattern I
first learned about from Ryan Cole a
pathologist who noticed this in all of
the samples coming across his desk now
remember a pathologist is a unique kind
of doctor because he's not seeing tons
of patients which limits the number of
people he can see what he's seeing is
huge numbers of samples from all sorts
of doctors who are sending him stuff and
saying what is this so he was in a
position to see much more broadly than
other people and he was bold enough to
say what he was seeing and he was
talking about the cancers he was seeing
very very early on and the reason I
raise him specifically at this moment
not only is this potentially relevant to
the integration of random DNA fragments
from these vaccines but Ryan Cole is
currently fighting to preserve his
license what he he is literally um
facing a uh I don't know what the right
term is tribunal but a yeah a tribunal
evaluating whether or not he can
continue to practice medicine which is
absurd Ryan Cole has been ahead again
and again and again on this topic and
he's being punished for it and this is
happening right here in the west right
now that's that's that's terrifying um
what do we know about what conditions
are necessary and sufficient uh if if we
know that much um for um chopped up
pieces of DNA that are floating about uh
to integrate with your own I don't think
uh put it this way I'm no expert my
guess is that because what you have is
an elaborate set of Machinery in the
cell designed to do all kinds of things
like repair broken DNA so if you dump a
bunch of broken DNA into the cell that
the cell is not expecting it may respond
by going into repair mode and that may
end up integrating things that you
wouldn't want to integrate
so I would say look okay so maybe no
nothing extraordinary is required at all
maybe I think nothing extraordinary is
required why nothing extraordinary is
required is a story others would be
better positioned to explain but let's
just put it this way it is reckless to
be dumping a chaotic assortment of DNA
fragments into uh a human being
because you know it's a welcome to
complex systems moment what's going to
happen if you do that well the answer is
almost anything can happen but high on
the list of things you would expect
would be uh can answers why well this
goes back to my work actually the idea
that we are riddled with what I called
protot tumors which are would be tumors
that have been arrested as as they've
run out of the capacity to
duplicate those are tumors except that
they don't have toras turned on you know
could random fragments introduced into
the genome activate toras and for which
every cell in your body has the code
right they could so I don't know how all
these things fit together but it's like
of all the Reckless things you could do
dumping a bunch of random fragments of
information into a uh an information
system like this on which your health
depends couldn't be crazier but the link
to what you were presenting a couple
weeks ago
is they ran the clinical trials with the
vaccines produced under procedure one
all right and then they switch to
procedure two to scale it up up thereby
not providing any information on the
actual Hazard of vaccines produced by
technique 2 when they very well could
have used technique 2 for the stuff that
they tested in the clinical trials so
the the the different method um may very
well have and there's no reason to think
it didn't have created a different
product and therefore having tested
product one um but bringing product to
to Market um means that the product that
is on Market has not been tested yes
exactly has not been tested and this
would you know a a witting Pharma
attempting to obscure hazards from their
uh let's face it utterly
crappy uh production mechanism uh that
is utterly riddled with not just the
design defects in the vaccine itself but
the impurities that come from lousy
quality control right of course in order
to hide those things it would do this it
would have some very careful you know
it's like giving the reviewer of uh an
automobile a version that was
specifically tailored to make them happy
rather than reflect what the consumer is
going to see right it's slight of hand
um okay before we go to the second piece
of video I know this has taken a long
time but before we go to the
um I want to highlight one other odd
fact of this award having been given for
this narrow piece of the MRNA vaccine
technology not only does that
effectively admit what Robert Malone has
been saying and what alexandr marinos
validated that he is the inventor of the
MRNA vaccine technology long since uh
out of patent but I I don't think that
this award demonstrates that it admits
it tacitly because what they're trying
to do is validate the vaccines and
they've given the award for a narrow
piece of technology that is an interpret
I do not think that that is the only
interpretation I I can't find another
one that would make sense other than
they don't want to validate Malone
because Malone has some things to say
about how this technology has been
utilized but anyway we can leave that
aside
nonetheless the pseudo urine
stabilization of these uh vaccines of
the mrna's in these
vaccines is I think the greatest design
defect on a long list of design defects
in these vaccines now um I said that to
Robert Malone the day the award was
given and he said no he thinks the spike
protein the choice of Spike protein is
the greatest designed defect but let's
just say that there's a debate to be had
between those the spike protein is
cytotoxic as we were famously fact
checked for pointing out on Dark Horse
but anyway it is cytotoxic it is um but
the MRNA transcript means that it is
produced far are longer in the body so I
guess there's a debate to be had about
which of these things is dumber but um
they're both pretty dumb and one of them
just got a Nobel Prize uh so that's a a
fascinating fact right this this Nobel
Prize was literally given for a a design
defect of the vaccines not arguably one
of their uh strengths all right so let's
go to this next piece of
video this is um a podcast from January
2021 so that same moment that nature was
uh describing the many side effects that
the MRNA platform brings right and the
guest on this podcast is Drew Weissman
who just won the Nobel Prize for this at
that point was still two and a half
years from winning the Nobel Prize right
and uh I will say I'm going to criticize
many of the things he says but let us
remember that some of these criticisms
have to be tempered by the fact that we
hadn't yet vaccinated billions of people
and therefore the amount of information
about the actual consequence of that was
much less how so how can we be sure that
this vaccine will not cause long-term
negative impact in humans like that's
one of our big questions that we hear a
lot so Ian the the first is to
understand what the vaccine is the the
MRNA in the vaccine is identical to the
RNA in your
cells so the the RNA in yourselves isn't
causing long-term Adverse Events so the
RNA and the vaccine won't either the RNA
is degraded probably within a week it's
completely
gone the lipid nanoparticles contain
four types of fat two of the fats are
identical to what's in our cells they're
they're
physiologic the other two are present at
incredibly low levels they are gone
within 24 to 48 hours
they're just you the body degrades them
they're gone so nothing of the vaccine
is left after days to a week or
so the question that comes well then how
do you get a long-term adverse event
well you can't from any components of
the vaccine because they're gone the the
MRNA does not integrate into the DNA it
doesn't affect the DNA it
doesn't all right so there are a number
of things to point out here um the
biggest error that he makes he makes
right up front he says that the MRNA is
identical to the MRNA in your cells and
from this he derives a tremendous amount
of comfort his point is essentially look
this is in you already how could
introducing a little more of it possibly
hurt you and this is the biggest piece
of garbage one can imagine for one thing
this is the guy whose invention is
making this a very unnatural thing for
which there is no natural analog in your
body so put aside what his actual
invention was for a moment which makes
what he said just patently not true and
he knows
it even if it were
true mRNA is built of certain things and
even if the MRNA that was in his
invention was built of exactly the same
things which it de facto cannot be
because the whole point is that he's
using something new but even if it were
the fact that it uses the same
materials but has instructions to to
make a particular protein is the point
so the idea you know we don't have in us
the instruction set to produce the spike
protein we don't you and I don't many
people do now right if they if they
receive these vaccines so um the you
know the grotesque obvious error there
is no but dude you literally did the
thing that changes the MRNA such that
it's less transient such that it's more
stable such that it stays uh in the body
for longer and that's not what we have
in our bodies already but even if that
weren't true the whole point is that it
is an instruction set it's a factory for
creating something in particular which
in this case they chose the spike
protein oopsy right so this is um
crazy at three levels three okay yeah
the first level is the MRNA itself isn't
like a natural M mRNA because you
altered it dude right so that's one two
is that it is
informationally novel and it is
therefore causing your body to produce
something that is not naturally in it
and so the thing that is produced could
be good could be bad but it ain't just
your stuff so the whole argument that
you're doing this anyway this won't this
doesn't change anything is like an
argument designed to fool people who
don't know anything and then the third
thing so we've got the modification you
made makes the MRNA itself not
natural um and it's not the only way
it's not natural either by the way this
mRNA was codon optimized for the human
environment it has had modifications to
uh the spike protein sequence for
various functional reasons but the point
is it it this just is not natural the
informational content produces something
which could be a toxin that could be a
substitute for some thing that you
should be producing but don't but but
the point is the it's saying that you
know that thing is not dangerous because
it's made of the same materials in your
toaster yes but it's a firearm right
yeah but it's made of the same stuff in
your toaster you're not arguing that you
know toasters are deadly are you right
so it's like that kind of argument okay
so that's one and two yeah and then the
third one
is if you produce a protein that you
were not producing early in your
development it is a signal to your
immune system to attack your cells it
tells your immune system that your cells
have been infected by a virus and the
correct response to that is to destroy
your own tissue so not even if the
protein itself that was encoded by the
MRNA was itself inert the fact that it
is novel to your body means that it will
trigger your body to do damage to itself
so that's three different ways this is
nonsense well the trigger your body to
do damage to itself is the same trick as
in traditional vaccines right the I'm
I'm going to introduce an antigen that
can hopefully get your immune system's
attention quickly and efficiently and
cause it to recognize kill and remember
so you know that that is the basis on
which traditional vaccines function well
yes and no there are various traditional
vaccines there's one traditional
platform and it's actually the one that
I would say is the safest that uses this
trick but in a very different way yes an
attenuated virus does cause some of your
tissues to produce a forign protein that
will get them attacked but and I believe
this point this is this is a point that
I believe has only been made here on
Darkhorse the lipid
nanoparticle
encoding an mRNA message is effectively
a
pseudovirus an actual virus that has
been attenuated has an ecology it has a
mechanism of action that will inherently
limit what tissues it invades yes the
next thing that this guy this now no
Bell lauriat goes on to talk about is
the fats that are are used to get this
into tissues and the key thing to
understand you probably all learned in
high school like dissolves like fats
like fats fats dislike water they like
fat they've coated this mRNA in fat your
cells are cated in fat this is a
mechanism of distribution that has no
targeting whatsoever that means it will
by by Design explicitly right so so as
to protect uh the MRNA in the
intercellular space from the
mrnes um long enough for it to get into
cells well it's not just to protect it
and in fact it probably doesn't even
need protection because it's so pseudo
iDine stabilized that the MRNA Aces
aren't going to take it apart but the
idea is just as soap bubbles join soap
bubbles are made of the same stuff when
they touch each other they join and they
can become two soap bubbles can become
one big soap bubble so that's how cell
membranes work too and this is like a
pseudo membrane the the lipid
nanoparticle is functioning like a
pseudomembrane and it bumps up against
the cell and then it spills its contents
into the cell but the point is it
doesn't choose what cell it's going into
unlike any virus so to the extent that
you might make the argument that this is
doing the same thing as an attenuated
virus vaccine the attenuated virus
vaccine is inherently self-limiting in
terms of what tissues just note that you
we have we were talking
about one two and three ways um that um
that this is not just you know just like
taking stuff in that's identical to
what's in your body and your third item
on that list I was saying um sounds very
much like um what traditional vaccines
do but but um the the rejoiner that you
make is the critical one and yes we have
talked about that here before which is
that an attenuated virus vaccine um
actually has an organism or a virus um
that exists in nature and that has some
experience with you as a host not you an
individual but you the species if it
didn't then you would not be getting
vaccinated against this thing um and so
it will go after particular tissues not
be indiscriminate whereas a nanolipid
covered piece of mRNA is has no
evolutionary history in a human host at
all and therefore will be indiscriminate
in what cells it attaches itself to yes
and the other traditional kind of
vaccine that is now used where fragments
of a pathogen are introduced in order to
induce an immune response that doesn't
enter cells at all and so that is that
is not causing your immune system to
Target your own cells it doesn't do this
in any way so in any case what he's what
he's saying is pure nonsense at multiple
levels this is not a natural thing that
you should feel like oh I'm really you
know it it's a little bit like saying
GMOs uh we've been genetically modifying
organisms for a thousand years so relax
right for thousands of years so relax
and the answer is no actually you've
genetically modified that organism so
you can dump a bunch of pesticide on it
how good is that pesticide for me right
should I be worried about GMOs yes I
should be for multiple reasons including
that one but selective reading right not
the same thing right it's slight of hand
it's logical slight of hand designed to
fool people who don't know a lot um and
not knowing a lot isn't the fault of
anybody it's just you didn't study this
thing enough to spot their lies but um
but those of us who did uh this is a
really weird thing for somebody who just
got a Nobel Prize to be saying about
their own invention because he's got to
know it's wrong um again this is him
talking two and a half years ago uh true
but he sure as hell knew yes uh that
this wasn't just mRNA like the stuff
floating around in your body because
he's the world's expert in modifying
mRNA to stabilize it and put it into's
bodies right I mean come on okay so just
a couple more points he says that this
is degraded within uh a couple days or
at most a week well let's put it this
way if that was comforting in 2021 if
you really believe that in 2021 then he
ought to be alarmed in 2023 because we
now know it doesn't limit itself that
it's there for months so why is he not
now sounding the if that was comforting
then he ought to be alarmed now and he
doesn't appear to be he then says well
there are four types of fats and two of
them are natural so don't worry well I
would love in the nanolipid and the
lipid nanop particles yeah and then he
says the two that aren't natural um
they're there at very low levels uh what
is very low levels mean is this the same
very low levels of the uh assurances
that the Mercury and the vaccine that
you want me to inject into my kid isn't
a problem is it that kind of low levels
right like what does low levels even
mean and then he says and it's gone
within 24 to 48 hours because the body
degrades it now wait a second are you
telling me that you've just introduced a
novel lipid
that doesn't exist in my body but my
body's expert at disassembling it I want
to check that it's maybe that's true but
that is not a slam dunk and the fact
that you can't find it doesn't mean it
isn't there especially if you're not
looking very hard um so he says nothing
of the vaccine is left uh after days or
a week which again if that was
comforting in 2021 it ought to be
alarming now and he says the MRNA does
not integrate into the DNA which again
might be true but he says it does
nothing to the DNA again maybe that was
believed then but we now know that
there's lots of DNA contaminating these
vaccines that it is getting into people
and it appears to be integrating into
their nuclear genomes well that's that's
that's a different response though if so
I'm seeing your notes rather than
remembering what he said y um that these
mRNA like the MRNA vaccine does nothing
to the
DNA um is not a response to um these
mRNA vaccines are contaminated with
DNA I agree but again I'm not arguing
that from his perspective in 2021 that
he necessarily knew how these things
were going to be produced or that there
was going to be contamination maybe he
did given what he's willing to say about
the naturalness of the mrnas which he
knows aren't natural I wouldn't put it
past him but even if he was naive
then we should be seeing a different
thing unfold now we should not be seeing
a Nobel Prize be awarded by people who
say that there isn't an adverse event
signal really this is just pure theater
you've got the most prestigious prize in
the world being awarded by people who
can't even avoid saying obviously wrong
things in a press conference they can't
you know there's not enough vagueness in
the world for them to avoid absolute
lies in their press conference that's
stunning
they would give a prize that can't be
defended um without having to lie oh
okay well I guess that's where we are
but but the final thing I will say is
that I
believe we knew that the Nobel process
was corrupt many people have in the
aftermath of this pointed out uh Obama's
Peace Prize which is ironic was given to
him before he had the chance to do such
terrible things and then his reflects
very poorly on that choice um this is
not the only place these these prizes uh
are uh really uh quite a political
phenomenon um but the degree to which
farma capture and whatever Travels With
It has obviously completely uh owned
this process and is now delivering um
prizes for design defects in products
that it wishes to to expand the market
for that's pretty amazing and what I
what dawned on me in reflecting on this
was we are now living in an
era in which it is literally true that
anything plugged into a major
institution is compromised anything
scientific that is plugged into a major
institution is compromised which does
not mean that there is no science
there's lots of science but the only
science that is in any way trustworthy
IS ragtag F itive science right you've
got people who still know how to do
science existing outside of the
institutions right you've got uh you
know a band of rebels who insist on
still doing the job even though um
Pharma and its cronies have attempted to
stamp it out everywhere that it's
supposed to be done that's a strange era
to be living in but at least if you
start with that premise you will not be
so confused by all of the garbage that
is emerging from all of the places that
at one time might have been trusted to
tell you what was going
[Music]
on